and she goes and cheats on him for like
three days and then he like runs in the
rain and is like I love you and then she
leaves her fiance for this guy she dated
in high school she's an alpha Widow bro
yeah I actually never saw it but I had a
podcast guest who was explaining the
plot of it to me I was like this is this
is horrible yeah horrible Story the
alpha the alpha Widow is like it's it's
really common in music and movies can we
do like a sequel to every Hallmark movie
ever where it's like so the woman who's
got a fiance and he's like a snooty
businessman and then she goes back home
to see her parents and then there's the
the nerdy guy who's all grown up and
Suave and he's a carpenter now and he's
ripped and then he's very nice to her
and she realized he was the one all
along can we just have like a part two
where it's like they had a one night
stand and he was like yo I'm done like I
got things to do yeah I've seen you in
20 years later produce it I'll be I'll
act you know no this happens right